[Music]
on this friday night
long weekend warning the last hurrah of
summer
doesn't spell the end of covet 19. now
is the time
to get serious what health officials
want you to avoid
our interview with america's top
infectious disease dr anthony fauci's
fears and we can have some significant
problems and
his reality check on when a covid19
vaccine could be ready
recognizing the rights and wrongs of
historical canadian
figures it's not black and white it's
great the push to present the good
the bad and the ugly from our country's
past
and raptor's rapture
the buzzer beater we can't stop watching
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we head into the labor day long
weekend it may feel like the last gasp
of summer before we begin to hunker down
for fall and winter
and as much as we all want to forget
about kovid 19
now is not the time in several provinces
the daily number of new cases is already
on the rise and that's before schools
are fully reopened and
before the weather changes and we need
to spend more time inside
so you may not want to hear it but this
is the message about big parties
this weekend anyone who's thinking
they're having a big shin dig
this this weekend forget about it cancel
it folks just
follow the protocols i don't care if
it's those doobies joints whatever you
want to call them or drinks or right
just don't share them
simple and wear a face covering
ahead of the weekend quebec ontario
alberta and bc remain the key provinces
of concern
today there were 184 new cases reported
in quebec
148 in ontario and in alberta 164
more people tested positive today and
121
in bc there is some good news the recent
spike in cases has not led to a similar
spike in hospitalizations
since the peak of the first wave in
spring there's been a steady decline of
people in the hospital and in icu with
covid19
a big reason for that is many of
canada's recent infections have been in
younger people who have mild or no
symptoms
that is great but the risk is they can
spread it to others who
are more vulnerable listen to bc's
public health officer
we're at that limit we're at that
precipice if you will
where we need to take the actions to
ensure that we can move forward into the
fall
and keep our curve low
in the u.s there are still roughly 40
000 new cases of covid19
every day and the leading american
expert on infectious diseases dr anthony
fauci
is nervous about that fauci who is on
the white house coronavirus task force
would like that number to shrink to
below ten thousand daily cases and he's
anxious
about how americans will behave over the
labor day weekend fauci spoke to our
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
who's with me now jackson donna like
many scientists dr fauci worries that
the worst is yet to come this fall and
winter as a second wave of the virus
coincides with the seasonal flu
and so i started by asking him about a
new projection a new covid19 model here
in the u.s
which forecasts the number of deaths in
this country could more than double
between now and january
to 410 000 well it is a concern because
you know if you look at the background
the baseline of what we have it's
unacceptably high
so what you would have liked to see like
for example new york city metropolitan
area
got hit very badly there was a period of
time there
where 50 of all of the cases and
hospitalizations
were coming out of the new york
metropolitan area but when they went up
and peaked and came down
they are now at a very low baseline like
one percent or less
positivity but if you look at the
country as a whole
our baseline is very very high and right
now it's about 30 to 40
000 or more cases per day if we go into
the fall
with that high level of a baseline then
you add the risk
of indoor activity because of the cooler
weather
then we can have some significant
problems you know i know a lot of
canadians are watching the situation
down here in the us
and they're very worried about it and
there certainly doesn't seem to be a
huge appetite
for example for reopening the border but
i'm curious
your perspective as a medical expert is
there still a benefit
in travel restrictions do they serve a
purpose at this point in controlling the
spread of the virus
you know in some respects it does i mean
if you have a
an area a country as a whole or an area
of the country with very very low
activity
obviously there's concern about letting
people in
from the outside other countries in
which there's a high rate of infection
you know sometimes it does have a
positive effect of keeping the lid on
things
but sometimes you know it just doesn't
make that much difference so there is
always this
argument as to the benefit or not of
doing that
people will still argue on either side
of that
when we talk about a potential vaccine
and there seems to be optimism about
maybe identifying a successful candidate
by the fall but can you put that in
realistic terms what does that actually
mean realistically for rolling out at
mass distribution
you can start thinking about the
deployment of that vaccine
at the end of the year the beginning of
the first quarter of the first half of
2021
and as we get well into 2021 there
likely would be enough doses for
everyone who needs it
because the companies are talking about
pre-making
ahead of time hundreds of millions of
doses
it almost feels like there's sort of two
different message tracks out there right
now
on one hand there's a lot of hope about
a vaccine perhaps being
ready at least by the fall and advances
in therapeutics and on the other hand
you know fears of a second wave for
example and the rising rates that you
mentioned
and i'm curious if that confusion if you
worry that that's going to lead to a
sense of complacency among the public
you know we've been going through this
stress and strain
you know everything from the economy to
interruption of
regular services to just the fatigue of
having to be
locked down to a greater or lesser
degree you know ever since february and
march it's now
september and we're still in that boat
so i'm concerned that people are going
to get so discouraged
they're going to loosen up the kinds of
attention
to public health measures which we need
to continue to focus on if we're going
to keep this under control
and we know things are reopening on
different timelines and places in canada
and the us and so i asked dr
fauci if there's one thing he will
refuse to do even when he's allowed to
he said unequivocally he will not go
into a bar even when they reopen
he said they're simply a bad idea no
matter where you are because as the
drinks go down
the masks come off and the social
distancing pretty quickly disappears
donna okay jackson prosco in washington
thanks
avoiding crowded bars is advice that's
worth repeating
in quebec city a karaoke bar has become
the epicenter of what public health
officials call
a super spreader event as mike armstrong
explains it's also a cautionary tale
ahead of the holiday weekend there's a
sign on the door at bala kirwac in
quebec city that says simply
closed until further order due to the
coronavirus
but health officials this week are
warning the problem was actually
covid19 and karaoke
it's very important to say right now
hey guys it's dangerous
officials say a night of sharing
microphones and singing at the kirowak
was a super spreader event 58 cases have
been traced directly to patrons from one
night
august 23rd but it didn't stop there
it was passed from patrons to at least
10 other people
including three children at three
different schools
add to that dozens of people who came
into contact with them
who are now home as a precaution the
cases
are increasing every day and this is not
good news quebec's health minister is
warning the public that things that
seem innocent can be dangerous whether
it's karaoke or a backyard barbecue
he says there was a case this week north
of montreal where a simple dinner party
for 17 people
turned into 14 positive tests
for labor day weekend i would just ask
everybody
to pay special attention the way you
meet with your neighbors
you meet with your family schools in
quebec started reopening last week the
province now says
47 have had coronavirus cases but so far
there have only been a couple of schools
where people actually contracted the
virus
and most of them it was caught somewhere
else taken into the school and didn't
spread
past that one person mike armstrong
global news
montreal there is a snapshot of job
growth in the u.s
and canada tonight canada is just over
one million jobs away from reaching
pre-pandemic employment levels
nearly 250 000 jobs were added in august
most of them full-time
the unemployment rate dropped from 10.9
percent in july to 10.2 percent in
august
the jobless rate is higher for
racialized workers stats canada says
arab black and southeast asian canadians
continue to have the highest
unemployment rates
and employment for indigenous people
living off reserve decreased by nearly
two percent last month the american
unemployment rate dropped below
10 percent in august it fell from 10.2
percent in july to 8.4 in august
1.4 million jobs were added in august
that's the fewest since the pandemic
began and about half of the 22 million
jobs lost since march in the u.s
have now returned women who took the
biggest employment hit have made the
biggest rebound
and people of color continue to face a
worse job market
impact from the pandemic recession than
their white counterparts
in the u.s president trump and his aides
are scrambling to defuse the fallout
from a scathing report that claims
he's called fallen american troops
losers and suckers
the allegations he denigrated american
soldiers were made in the magazine the
atlantic
the article quotes four anonymous
sources and among their claims that
trump called off a visit to a cemetery
of american war graves in france in 2018
reportedly asking aides why should i go
to that cemetery
it's filled with losers on memorial day
in 2017 trump visited the virginia
gravesite of his former secretary of
homeland security's
son who was killed in afghanistan in
2010. the article claims trump said
i don't get it what was in it for them
trump has called soldiers losers before
this is what he said about senator john
mccain who died two years ago
mccain was a decorated navy veteran who
spent years
as a prisoner of war in vietnam i
supported him he lost he let us down
but you know he lost so i never liked
him as much after that because i don't
like losers
but frank frank let me get to it he hit
me
he's not a war hero he's a warrior five
and a half years
he's a war hero because he was captured
today in the oval
office trump said this about the
atlantic article
no it was a fake story written by a
magazine that was probably not going to
be around much longer
and his democratic rival joe biden whose
son served in iraq
his reaction was scathing my son
volunteered joined the united states
military
as the attorney general and went to iraq
for a year
won the bronze star and other
commendations he wasn't a sucker
the service men and women he served with
particularly those did not come home
were not
losers if these statements are true
the president should humbly apologize
to every gold star mother and father
and every blue star family that he's
denigrated and sold it
who the heck does he think he is
there are new developments tonight in a
global news investigation about conduct
in the rcmp
for the first time since a lawsuit was
launched alleging top leadership in the
rcmp
ignored complaints about cameron orders
for years a former top cop
is responding ordest you'll remember was
the senior intelligence official with
the mounties who faces criminal charges
is accused of selling top secret
intelligence
the new civil suit launched this week
alleges orders bullied staff
targeting the same employees whose top
secret intelligence reports
he allegedly sold or offered to canada's
enemies
now former commissioner bob paulson says
he never protected orders from any
complaints though he says they had a
friendly relationship abigail beeman has
been looking into what's going on
abigail donna bob paulson declined
on-camera interviews but in a series of
emails with global news reporters he was
defensive he told us he was feeling
quote set upon by you people
several sources tell global news ortiz
and paulsen were very close and
paulson was key to ortiz's rapid rise
within the force
while paulson paints a different picture
i never personally promoted cam and he
never worked directly for me
my relationship with cam was friendly
and as i've said i was always impressed
with him
i note that up until his publicly
announced arrest i had no
inkling that he was suspected of having
done these criminal acts
or that he was managing poorly or that
he was a bully or had harassed anyone
the lawsuit alleges formal complaints
about ordis began in january 2017.
paulson retired later that year the
plaintiffs say they continued to raise
concerns until january 2020
when the force launched an internal
review that ultimately found management
failed to
act global news spoke with a retired
civilian member of the rcmp
who knew two of the plaintiffs i highly
respected
their work they are they're excellent
intelligence analysts
and very experienced intelligence
analysts
if the allegations that they are are
making are true and i have no reason
to disbelieve them they have been
treated
absolutely abominably by the
organization
and angus smith who also worked in the
same department as ortis for years
says he wasn't surprised by the
lawsuit's allegations of inaction
he's seen a number of red flags get
ignored
in my 30-year career that was certainly
a pattern that i did
observe abigail what about those in
charge at the rcmp right now
what are they saying well this week the
rcmp told global news they're launching
a
management action plan in response to
that internal review but that report was
handed in
four months ago and the rcmp is not
offering any timeline for
action nor did they answer questions
about whether they have or will
investigate claims of favoritism and
then there's current
commissioner brenda lucky while neither
she nor paulson are named as defendants
in the case
there is a specific allegation she
ignored email complaints about ordis
from one of the plaintiffs
we asked the rcmp for a response from
lucky to that direct allegation
but we're only told they won't comment
on matters before the courts
donna all right abigail beeman in ottawa
thank you
the search continues in beirut coming up
still holding out hope a month
after the deadly blast
in bay road searchers have been digging
for more than 30 hours now holding out a
tiny glimmer of hope someone may still
be alive
trapped in the rubble after that massive
blast a month ago
searchers including a team from chile
detected what they think were signs of
life in the rubble of this building
special sensory equipment picked up a
pulsing signal what could be a heartbeat
they were first alerted to the area by
this sniffer dog named flash who's
become a bit of a hero in beirut
searchers brought in scanning equipment
to create 3d images of the wreckage and
a camera
so far they found no one
we have been able to acquire precise
three-dimensional data and so far this
has not
not shown any body
inside people have gathered to watch and
there are calls for silence every time
the searchers need to listen for signals
they say they won't give up until they
know what they're dealing with
today a moment of silence was held in
tribute to the nearly 200 people killed
on august 4th
when a warehouse at the port full of
ammonium nitrate
detonated a home in oshawa ontario has
been cordoned off by the police after
five people were found dead inside the
house early this morning
police say four men and a woman are dead
including the gunman
at least two of the victims are minors
investigators say they were all from the
same family
a sixth person a 50-year-old woman
described by police as
a mother is recovering in hospital from
gunshot wounds
it was a quite a chaotic scene even for
the residents
in the area a lot of callers calling in
stating that they were
hearing a lot of the gunshots a lot of
screaming coming from this residence
investigators are looking at whether a
white ford pickup truck with manitoba
plates might be connected and this
afternoon they found what they call an
unknown device inside the house and
secured the area
police say there is no ongoing threat
still ahead how a canadian cemetery is
reframing history to reflect
a fuller picture
the toppling of sir john a mcdonald's
statue in montreal sparked a debate over
who we choose to honor and how we
explain
the full picture of their past michael
couture has the story of one cemetery
that's found a way to add
context that reflects reconciliation
in a city of monuments there's a renewed
debate over how to honor the
accomplishment of historic canadians
while acknowledging their dark history
perhaps the answer lies with beechwood
national cemetery's plaque program
years ago it started reframing legacies
like that
of duncan campbell scott yes this person
was a phenomenal poet
but yes he instituted a
system that killed children all across
canada
scott was the indian affairs minister
under prime minister john a macdonald
and was known as the architect
of the residential school system
following the truth and reconciliation
commission
scott's plaque in the cemetery was
changed to reflect that fact
it's not black and white it's gray and
that's where people really
have to understand that history should
be
sort of understood in the gray area
those gray areas appear on several
bronze plaques that dot the cemetery
while
others herald the heroes of the time
in 1922 peter henderson-bryce wrote a
report
calling the residential schools a
national crime
it was ignored and dismissed by the
government
that report was published in this
building
just steps away from parliament when do
canadians have an opportunity to learn
from their true history
in a way that builds a better country
going forward cindy blackstock wants a
plaque to be put
on the james hope and sons building i
think people
have a different reaction to actually
looking at a building and can imagine
for themselves someone walking in there
with a report
that could have saved thousands of
children's lives had the government of
canada only listen
it's one of eight buildings on a
self-guided walking tour of
reconciliation put together by the first
nations child
and family caring society blackstock
wants the government to recognize the
buildings
and the unsung heroes of the time as we
go forward
we need to be very mindful and and make
more space for
for these people whom we've largely
forgotten in
in in the past at the same time the
government continues to grapple with the
uncomfortable truths about canada's
founders
and how to reframe their legacies to
include the good
and the bad michael couter global news
ottawa
next that buzzer beater
[Applause]
point five to go in game three
oh gee with a look got it i know you've
probably all seen
it already but can you watch this moment
enough with half a second left on the
clock toronto's og aninobi
calmly sunk that three-pointer and
walked off like it was no big deal
toronto beat the boston celtics by one
point and kept the raptors dream alive
in the nba playoffs just remarkable
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the sun setting over jones
lake in moncton new brunswick
thanks for watching i'll see you again
next week take care of yourselves and
have a lovely weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
bye